eh con 48% de los votos escrutados el
apruebo tiene un 37% de los votos
Mientras que el rechazo lidera con un
amplio margen de 63% eso sería con 48%
de las botas escrutados es lo mismo que
estamos viviendo aquí en el colegio
Liceo aplicación donde ya queda tan solo
una mesa realizando el conteo Y dónde se
escucha también de manera seguida la
opción del rechazo el ánimo ha decaído
en este sector al menos aunque también
vemos que hay personas que ya empiezan a
aparecer en Plaza Italia al centro
neurálgico de las manifestaciones y del
estallido Social que empiezan a juntarse
empieza a ver un ambiente de que el
rechazo se está imponiendo como habían
apuntado las encuestas sin embargo con
un margen mucho más amplio por el
momento por lo menos en el lugar en el
que nosotros estamos hay una sensación
sin duda de un poco de pesimismo
Patricia
Bueno si los resultados parecen ser por
lo menos la tendencia prácticamente
Irreversible estamos llegando casi al
50% de las mesas escrutadas contanos
patricias durante todos estos días
previos porque se han estado
pronunciando tanto desde el oficialismo
los sectores que respaldan a Gabriel
borich como desde la oposición sobre
este posible y eventual rechazo que
muchos sondeos venían anticipando de
hecho desde el oficialismo plantearon ya
adelantaron algunos cambios que se
podrían hacer cuéntanos Cómo fueron esas
reacciones que hubo de ambos sectores
previendo ya este escenario
Así es la verdad es que el rechazo venía
liderando las encuestas Desde incluso
antes de que se acabara el texto
constitucional y lo había hecho de forma
bastante importante en las últimas en
los últimos meses en las últimas semanas
se había reducido un poco pero el
gobierno que siempre fue prueba a prueba
antes incluso de ser gobierno sí que
empezó a planear las posibilidades de
que el rechazo se impusiera en el día de
hoy y rompiendo así una de las máximas
electorales de que uno nunca da por
descontado que puede ganar Y desde ahí
del oficialismo haya habido varias
opciones desde la planteada por el
propio congreso que redujo el quórum
para rechazar para reformar la actual
constitución pero también el presidente
boricha afirmó que si se imponía el
rechazo iba a haber un nuevo proceso
Constituyente estaría por establecerse
es la forma en la que este proceso
saldría adelante pero sí que se hablaba
de plazos cortos de tiempo esto siempre
y cuando digamos en los resultados
electorales validarán un poco esa
necesidad de cambio la gran cuestión era
si el el margen de resultados era
bastante holgado como parece ser el caso
con que celeridad se van a realizar
estos cambios la idea principal era
tomar los textos que ya existían tomar
el texto de la propuesta de la
convención constitucional reformarlo ha
habido muchos partidarios de aprobar
para reformar como ha habido partidarios
de rechazar para reescribir
completamente y también tomar la
propuesta de el trabajo que había hecho
la presidenta Michelle bachelet que
también en su segundo mandato realizó un
importante trabajo para plantear una
nueva constitución un nuevo proceso en
el país desde el oficialismo esto era
algo de lo que se hablaba con
naturalidad de manera que se hablaba más
del postre el vestido y de los posibles
escenarios que del texto en sí o de la
posibilidad que ganara el apruebo Así
que es un tema que del que se viene
hablando mucho desde la élite y desde
desde la élite política y desde el
congreso desde hace días la acción será
todo esto pone mucha dificultad al
gobierno también de Gabriel borich que
por supuesto estaba a favor de la prueba
y que también tiene que realizar
reformas profundas en el país muy en la
línea de algunas de las planteadas por
el texto constitucional a partir de
ahora todos estaban el presidente
evorich realizó un discurso hoy en el
que manifestó que todos tenemos que
estar que todos tenían que estar
orgullosos de ser chilenos en un día
como hoy y que iba a liderar un proceso
tratando de lograr la unidad de todas
las partes Es algo lo que han incidido
No solo él sino también todos los
expresidentes que han votado hoy y que
han hecho declaraciones en el mismo
sentido toca ahora sentarse y empezar a
acuerdos acuerdos que pongan que de
alguna manera den una legitimidad a este
nuevo texto que fue la propia
ilegitimidad que tenía el texto
constitucional de la dictadura de
Augusto pinoche es lo que se trataba es
de lograr que este nuevo texto fuera
aprobado de forma transversal que
lograra la legitimidad por todas las
partes y eso va a llevar a que el
gobierno tenga que realizar muchos
acuerdos políticos para presentar una
reforma partiendo de lo que ya existe
que pueda convencer a la ciudadanía